the journey of a lifetime is about to
begin
we're on right now there's so many
amazing songs and seeing two they've
just outdone themselves they don't just
play in the background of a scene you
have real performances
there's such a wide spectrum of music
harvey mason jr creates all of the songs
for the film
i think i saw you
[Music]
hearing our cast sing and perform these
songs it's so exciting i'm do it again
he made me feel like such a pop star it
won't make it but i will he was like
just sing loud and from your heart and
i'm gonna take care of all the rest
having a chance to add in some new
talent brings a really cool flavor to
this we've got pharrell halsey bono from
u2 like
just crazy
doing a duet with bono it's very surreal
my 13 year old self was just like oh my
god how is this real
[Applause]
it's a testament to the way the audience
is connected to the first movie that
musicians of that caliber want to come
and be a part of it kid stays in the
movie
scene two is like being at a rock
concert
there's nothing holding me back
it's one of those movies that should be
seen with a group of people and sing out
loud and dance in the aisles
have some fun
come as you are with your own song take
the roof off you know the songs sing
along with them you want to get up and
dance in your seat and you know what
first behind it to say sit down maybe
turn around say would you like today
[Applause]